The first issue is that we need to do fast modular exponentiation.
One of the steps in the protocol is to compute the generator to the XA power modulo Q
where XA has to be some large random number.
And it has to be large and random because if an attacker can guess XA
well that would break the security of the protocol.
So we need to know that this is possible--
that we can do exponentiation more quickly than we can do discrete log.
So we're going to explore this with a quiz.
So how many multiplications are needed in order to compute 2 raised to the 20th power?
The straightforward way to do this would be to multiply 2 times 2 twenty times.
For the quiz, I want you to answer the minimum number of multiplications needed to compute this.
And I should point out that we're starting assuming that we don't know anything.
Obviously, if you already know the value of 2 to the 20, you can do it without any multiplications.